beth harmon's top five moves
who is beth harmon she is the star of
the netflix show queen's gambit
make sure you go and take a look it's
absolutely brilliant
now from one ginger to another we're
gonna go and take a look at those moves
make sure you like
and subscribe to the channel this first
example is taken quite early on
in the show where she's playing should
we say the kind of guy she
fancies who is towns this
gentleman scholar of a chess player and
this is supposed to be taken from the
1963 kentucky
state championships and here townes
grabs the pawn rook takes h6 a really
bad move a very
greedy move and that move is punished
how did beth now squeeze the rook
squeeze squeeze that rook until it had
no squares
to go to first she plays king
g7 that rook can only move
to h5 had the rook moved to h4
knight to a free check forks the king
and the rook leading to a winning
position
so rook to h5 is now met by king
to g6 this shows the power of having a
knight in the center
of the board the rook tries to escape
over to a5 where it looks like it may be
safe but i'll know
those knights are tricky little guys and
knight to b3 picks up the rook
with a winning game world on beth you
may be on your way to
greatness this second example taken from
her last round
in the kentucky state championships in
the
series this was based in 1963 and
propelled her on her way to
further success the game is actually
taken from the legendary
attacking player nets medinov and his
encounter
against kasparian from riga 1955
well done to the research of the show
they've done a fantastic job
and in this position the game continued
with black checking
but now after knight g6 the fireworks
start glowing like the color of her hair
rook to f7 in we go with a very powerful
check
the king steps forwards can you
calculate
the finish here queen takes g6
check the point of this move is the
remaining three pieces now combine
in a devastating attack normally three
pieces is the winning formula
when attacking your enemies king rook to
f6
check rook to g5 and the checks
keep on coming and after this move is
there any way to win
does beth want to draw she doesn't seem
like the kind of player who wants to
draw
rook h5 czech king g7 rook g5
and after the king moves to h7 the final
piece
lands with checkmate bishop to f5
kentucky state champion here i am this
next example taken from one of my
favorite scenes from the whole series
and
in this scene she's playing in mexico
city three years later on in her career
she's playing a young russian prodigy
who seems like a very nice chap i have
to say a lot of the people in the series
seem a lot nicer than some chess players
i've faced
and here she seals the winning move
what is the move that beth now sealed in
this position which is very hard to win
an actual an improvement in a real life
game which was dmitry yakuvenko of
russia
very strong grand master versus daniel
stellwagon
which occurred in the wimbledon of chess
wakanzi
in 2007. pawn
to h5 this is the winning breakthrough
beth's idea is to get a pawn to g6 where
she can support
rook h7 check mate now
black's best continuation here is
something like rook to e2
and now a4 giving the king the a3 square
which it can sneak itself onto after
rook takes b2 check the king
now perfectly safe black's best
defensive try
is h takes g5 and after h takes g6 we
see the point
rook h7 is what we call a rather juicy
threat
juicy black has to try rook h2
but now the hoover can come
let's hover up those pawns boys g4
rook takes a7 and if g3 beth
can simply swap off the rooks and this
position
is easily winning because the a and b
pawn will storm down the board
gaining a queen the next puzzle that i'm
gonna
give you guys is beth when she was
sitting in benny's apartment with
a number of the strongest american
players at the time
she was given this position by those
players in an attempt to maybe try to
trick her out or find
how strong she actually was it's white
to play and win
can you do a beth and find the move that
some of the
players in the scene struggle to find
and do pause if you need to of course
beth just slides out the move
king d7 i am the queen of the chessboard
and this is a brilliant move which stuns
the players
around her the point of this is that the
knight is now going to sneak
its way around mainly to the e8 square
if black tries bishop g7 the knight
comes to d6
next move it floats elegantly into e8
delivering
check mate if the king tries to run away
knight d6 is the winning move again if
the king goes to
f8 here there's knight to e6 oh yeah
nice checkmate if the king steps back
knight to e8 again and the last move
king to h6
i'll let you guys discuss and solve in
the comments below
now the last best sequence was her
should we say brilliant game at the end
of the series
against the russian player borgoff it
was held in moscow in the series in
1968. the game is actually based on
a game of evan chucks against patrick
wolf
where beth now improves on a van chuck's
play
with knight to e6 a much more direct
move aiming straight
for the black king the game continued
rook a4
a very critical game to decide who is
going to become champion
of this moscow tournament in the series
borgoth
playing very aggressively but rook takes
e4
beth continuing to march forward now
gaining
a seriously strong e pawn that e pawn
goes on
and around here in the series they
decide to adjudicate
in what is a critical and very dynamic
position
the real critical moment though appears
later on
when beth gets in with a check and after
king h8 borgoth
realizing what destiny might have for
him
offers a draw draw
beth thinks about decision a draw would
give her first equal
but she proves how brave she is by
finding the winning idea
can you find her winning move in this
position rook
is quite strong here anything to do that
no queen
takes f6 oh yeah
the idea is to get the rook on f1 into
f8 borgoth starts to sweat a little bit
pawn takes f6 rook takes f6 and now one
last
roll of the dice queen h5 hoping
for some perpetual beth keeps her call
rook to f8 check
e8 queen the queen queens
and becomes the queen now
rookie two check again going for some
per
petrol czech ideas king to f1 and best
queen slides away
in very good manner with king b2 the
king can't be checked
and bork off resigns like a gentleman
much more gentleman like than i've seen
some people resigning
beth becomes the champion and if you
haven't seen it
do go and watch it do go and watch it i
hope i haven't ruined
it too much for you you should have seen
it already if you haven't it's your own
fault
what can i say the queen's gambit really
is a pleasure to watch i'm assuming
you've watched it by now
if you haven't go and skive off work for
a couple of days
get netflix on get your you know choc
hot chocolate out sit there and just
enjoy
it's got its up and downs but it is
really just a brilliant
piece of artwork i'd say and the acting
is fantastic
i love everything about it and i really
hope we're gonna see
stronger female players like beth appear
in the chess scene in the future do like
and subscribe to this channel
and hopefully we'll be back with more
beth
like action in the future